hey everybody I'd be getting a lot of
requests to do a new Titans video and
they just announced a new cast member
that most of you might be at least a
little familiar with CMAs denver from
castle just joined the series remember
him as Detective Bryant I don't know why
detective Ryan I never figured you for a
believer all I know is my father's
cousin Raymond left this party in Jersey
one night he's driving back to Queens
and BAM blinding bright light comes down
from the sky next thing he knows it's
morning he's on the side of the Jersey
Turnpike
let me guess no memory of what happened
that is not called an alien abduction
that is called a hangover
maybe Raymond always was a lightweight
in the family he's mostly known for
playing characters like that detective
cop types so when he was announced they
said that they were keeping the person
that he was playing under wraps meaning
that he's a comic book character he's
probably relatively important to this
series there were all kinds of theories
people were asking me is he going to be
the Bruce Wayne of the series because a
while ago they were casting for someone
that looked like a young Jack Nicholson
Adam West type so it was like Oh clearly
they're gonna have some flashback scenes
too when Robin was younger when he was
with Batman learning things from him
that he'll apply to stuff in present day
so while it's totally possible it's a
valid theory I don't think that's who
he's playing there are a couple of other
big secret characters on the show like
this person that's supposed to be tied
to Trigon in the last couple of episodes
that they announced person wanted for
what was going to be the episode right
before the finale who was going to be
involved in what was going on in season
two that's right they're already
starting to tease stuff that's happening
in season two which I largely think is
going to build to the terror of Trigon
I've already done a video about that who
I think that person is so I'll link that
at the end of this
but CMAs Denver is probably playing
another detective cop type on the show
there are actually a couple different
really important ones from the Chuck
Dixon Nightwing era so if you haven't
read that it's Nightwing volume two it's
when he goes back to blüdhaven and
becomes a police officer
Wally's also trying to clean the streets
up at night what happens is that he
comes back to blüdhaven but he foils
this murder attempt that he just comes
across he gives the girl bus fare to go
back to Gotham City tells her to ask for
a job at Wayne tech tell them Dick
Grayson sent you then he takes the
criminal to the blood Haven Police
Department where he's booked by Delmore
red horn the police chief so really big
character who eventually becomes
Nightwing's boss when he becomes a
detective but that's one of the leading
candidates for who I think CMAs could be
playing on the show the other big
character is Dudley Soames he's sort of
this crooked cop or used to be a crooked
cop who winds up being an informant for
Nightwing so he's a good character with
this really checkered past
so because titans is a bit of a darker
series like when you think about the
darker DC TV shows like Black Lightning
or arrow
it sounds like Titans is gonna be even
darker than that so if they didn't cast
him to do the exact same thing as he did
on Castle which actors usually don't
like to do like they don't like to play
the exact same character every time they
go to a new TV show so he could be
playing somes
it's been very very long shot he could
be playing that character that's
connected to Trigon but it does sound
like because he's a relatively notable
actor he'll have a pretty big role my
church is a holy place and we strive
only to do good come now brother blood
isn't your church just a glorified cult
unlike you Brice I believe it in America
where all beliefs should be treated with
respect it's a shame the press doesn't
I'm afraid that's all we're going to get
from brother blood it even though they
haven't dropped any footage or anything
like that yet the actors are still
posting stuff from behind the scenes
they're still up in Toronto they're
gonna be filming till about the end of
April early May so it sounds like
they're really only filmed the first
couple of episodes so whoever he's
playing he shows up rel
Tivoli early in the run they usually
only announce actors like hey so-and-so
has been cast for X role right before
they get ready to film episodes but just
remember that the series was picked up
to series it's not like they're doing a
pilot and then judging that then
deciding whether or not to do episodes
they picked them up for the full 13
episodes and not to jinx anything but it
does sound like they're playing it like
they will get a season two because I
think they have a little more control
over whether or not it gets renewed and
that gets into a little bit of what
happens with international distribution
in how they get extra money from Netflix
in international territories it sounds
more confusing than it is but they're
actually doing it with shows like
Riverdale right now where even though
they produce it with CBS and CW in the
United States
Netflix becomes a really big financial
partner internationally so theory long
shot because Warner Brothers TV the
Berlanti verse has such a relationship
with Netflix internationally they might
also be the international partner for
shows like Titans and other berlanti
shows that they've released in the
future just because it's way more
efficient because everybody's getting it
at the same time and then you have the
shows like arrow and flash and a couple
of the other ones that are distributed
by Sky and other companies in the UK and
there's this crazy three week or four
week delay so people in Europe have to
wait a long time to watch the episodes
after people in the United States and
everywhere else get to watch them it is
the dumbest thing ever
so I think what the studios have
realized is that they're trying to move
to a more even distribution model where
everybody is getting the episodes at the
same time it cuts down on piracy and
even though Titan's is supposed to air
on the DC streaming service that might
just be in North America whereas
internationally like the way Netflix
does they have different companies
distributed even though depending on
which country you're in there's
different content that's available on
Netflix so I know it sounds a little bit
nuts but people have been worrying about
this DC streaming service especially
international people outside the United
States like how am I going to be
watching Titans how am I gonna watch
Young Justice Season 3
well Netflix is probably gonna be the
answer to that and just to make you feel
a little bit better about it
like for instance Young Justice season 3
was taken off of Netflix recently in
most countries I actually think that
Netflix just added it in Brazil I know
it sound
like a bit of a headache but don't worry
when Titans Young Justice all that new
stuff drops they will have ways of
distributing it internationally so
people will be able to watch it no
matter where they live even if you don't
get the DC streaming service it just to
give a bit of a Young Justice season 3
update these are a little bit of the
creator's talking about the upcoming
series in the new season there is gonna
be a time a bit of a time jump can't
reveal right now how long it is but in
following keeping with the tradition of
our previous seasons there will be some
some time that has passed we showed
three new characters who are members of
the team spoiler arrow add and thirteen
and we showed a lineup of characters who
are still with the team they're all a
little bit older a little bit more
experienced a little bit wiser as we
explored a lot of themes in our first
season of genetic experimentation with
the creation of Superboy visage genetic
experimentation to create a super power
beam to become a weapon our second
season we had aliens coming from out of
space kind of doing pretty much the same
thing and so as we've already kind of
revealed about our third season
metahuman trafficking the issue that is
the next next logical step in this story
from our first two seasons they're
definitely new members to the team
roster in season three I'm not saying
they're the only new members you know
the light is always our big bad and
Andale Savage they're all partners in
the light but vandals sort of the de
facto leader so vandal is kind of always
our big bad thank you fans thank you
thank you thank you so what will happen
is is my arrow episode video will post
next there'll be some new Avengers
Captain America stuff posting on Friday
but just leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below if there
is a new round of the Legion ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter
just be subscriber leave a comment about
DC step on the video click here for more
Titans and click here for brand new
flash footage thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight